what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back to discuss the
latest crazy chapter of dragon ball
super where we finally get to see what
vegeta's new form is capable of and what
it's called the hype definitely
continues so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy seeing these
dragon ball super reviews and want to
keep them coming channel the god of
destruction within and destroy that like
button hope you enjoyed that pun if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super and vegeta updates and
no one wants to miss vegeta updates now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called god of destruction power another
hype detail and i said last chapter that
i've never anticipated a dragon ball
super chapter quite as much as i did
this one and that is precisely because
we left off at vegeta's own new form now
we get to see what that form is capable
of and i love it as mentioned last
chapter granola is shocked and sweating
at the sight of this form notably not an
expression that goku managed to put on
his face granola questions vegeta about
his unbounded power and what that even
means another way of saying this is that
vegeta's limiters are off and that will
help to explain a lot of the actions
we'll see in this chapter again i want
to reiterate how much i love this form
and the aura that accompanies it too
can't wait to see this animated
eventually one day hopefully and the
form doesn't disappoint vegeta rushes in
and before granola knows it vegeta is
holding him up by his scarf it's one of
those classic tough guy moments and what
i said last chapter continues to stand
this is vegeta at his coolest he tells
granola the strongest fighter in the
world that he'll take him down a peg
since his head has gotten too big on a
side note that's such an ironic thing
for vegeta of all people to be pointing
out because this dude definitely gets a
big head whenever he unlocks a new form
and that's reflected in the vegeta head
dominated panel as well in an absolutely
brutal move vegeta headbutts granola and
as the latter winces and cops blood in
pain vegeta is smiling loving it he
takes granola and chucks him on the
ground vegeta speed is insane right now
and just as granola jumps up vegeta is
there waiting for him to smack him right
back down whatever the end of this
chapter is i love the fact that this
chapter is giving vegeta and his new
form a chance to shine it's never quite
that easy so we can't expect vegeta to
just get a definitive defeat right away
and that's the end of the arc that
wouldn't be that interesting that
wouldn't be that climactic but we still
get to enjoy these moments of vegeta
awesomeness and toughness it's like
after all this time of feeling guilty
about his past and trying to atone he's
finally let go of that and embraced pure
destruction in this battle at least we
can argue if that's the right move or
not but it definitely makes for a cool
vegeta we get more panels of vegeta and
his new form being in the clear lead
granola is getting hit around and in one
instance as he prepares to fire shot at
vegeta vegeta suddenly appears behind
him and knees him in the back truly some
great action this chapter finally
granola gets a hit in and vegeta didn't
even try to avoid it from the looks of
it and that's always a flex when you
smile and embrace an enemy's attack but
this arrogance of his may well be
vegeta's downfall again that being said
though i love seeing vegeta taking
pleasure and being pumped up by the pain
his veins are popping and he's sweating
after the attack but he's smiling and
talking about how the hotter his battle
soul burns the stronger he grows i love
it i know i keep saying this but i love
it then he takes granola's head in his
arms to granola shock and sends him into
the remains of the old city granola
treasures so much so that granola
himself is contributing albeit
indirectly to the destruction of it
something that must particularly
infuriate him then vegeta lands such a
satisfying kick and granola just shoots
through multiple walls and buildings and
the tower even falls over as granola
notes in this form it's like vegeta's
entirely different person granola notes
that he's getting stronger by taking
damage and wonders what's a god of
destruction then we get a bit of talk no
jutsu which is completely fine after a
bunch of action granola questions vegeta
whether it was this god he speaks of who
granted vegeta this power and vegeta
says no that power was awakened for the
first time in this battle it's his
innate power that comes from within him
this is important for vegeta because he
looks down on shortcuts like granola's
wish so he makes it clear yeah beerus
helped train him but vegeta earned this
form that came from within himself we
get a pretty funny moment where an
irritated granola asks if he drew out
this strength of vegeta's and vegeta not
only says yes but even says he's
grateful vegeta has proven to be so good
at pushing granola's buttons it's
hilarious and now he's saying that
rather than defeating him and getting
revenge for his people granolas just
made his enemies stronger hilarious
granola explodes in anger and launches
an attack at vegeta saying it's
impossible that vegeta is stronger than
him and instead of dodging vegeta again
takes it head on to granola surprise
vegeta truly seems unstoppable as he
laughs it off and says nothing refs him
up more but again he seems to be too
trusting of his ability to take on more
and more damage and granola takes
advantage of this with free shots and
keeps firing attacks at vegeta vegeta
finally jumps out of the smoke and is
about to land another attack at granola
and the terrified syria lien uses a new
technique for him i believe and raises
an energy shield around himself to
protect himself vegeta's got him on the
defensive and i cannot stress how much
better he's done than goku and pushing
granola goku was defeated twice without
getting close to pushing granola this
far so to people who dismissed vegeta's
new power as being weaker than goku's
current mui i can't see that being the
case obviously they both have much more
room to grow this is dragon ball after
all and that's part of the series but
the fact remains that god destruction
vegeta did much much better than mui
goku and just because ultra instinct is
an angel technique and vegeta's is a god
destruction technique it doesn't mean
vegeta can't surpass goku and vice versa
obviously vegeta won't always be in the
lead or even tied but switching back and
forth a bit is all i ask for but that
aside we return to the fight where
granola is wondering why vegeta doesn't
dodge like goku whose power avoids
danger and vegeta's response is classic
vegeta he mentions goku's ultra instinct
and says not to compare goku's pathetic
technique to his own so clearly vegeta
is putting himself above goku albeit he
is a very biased warrior who wants to
see himself on top but it's still
noteworthy since vegeta has had moments
when he acknowledged goku surpassed him
in the past then we get a very important
panel vegeta says kakarot's body may
have a mind of its own but um ego in
fact go ahead and call this ultra ego so
ultra ego vegeta instead of pursuing
goku's path double down on what some
might have considered his weakness and
attained this new power which at the
very least rivals goku's ultra instinct
and i really like that i like the fact
that the manga shows that there is more
than one way to become the strongest
they both work hard but they don't have
to work hard in the exact same way this
reminds me a bit of majin vegeta but the
big distinction is that this power was
within vegeta as he says it's not
borrowed which makes it even cooler as
vegeta rushes into the shield again
granola looks very panicked and we get
probably my favorite panel where
vegeta's power manages to break through
the shield and we get a close-up of him
kicking granola in the face it is an
absolutely priceless panel granola keeps
being upset he clearly appears to be on
the losing side and he's angry about it
saying there's no way he'll lose to some
third-rate saiyan who's not even frieza
it's funny how he has no idea that in
all likelihood unless frieza achieved
something crazy off screen vegeta is now
much stronger than frieza and although
there are moments where vegeta seems
like he loses it in this fight he also
has moments in this form like this one
where he's able to communicate
rationally he says that he has no idea
what granola heard but planet vegeta was
wiped out by frieza the same guy he
thinks vegeta is serving he drops the
crazy line that shows how much they have
in common where he says the same tribe
is yet another push to the brink of
extinction by frieza then oatmeal chimes
in oatmeal feels like granola's disney
cricket of conscience as he tells him
this contradicts what he's been told
grinnell doesn't want to let go of his
revenge which is pretty much his reason
for being at this point and keeps
fighting and i mean he's so invested
after sacrificing most of his life to
get his power he obviously doesn't like
accepting the fact that he made such a
big sacrifice for possibly nothing
granola punches vegeta in the head and
vegeta takes it again to granola
surprise one thing we can say about this
chapter is that granola was surprised by
vegeta more times than i care to count
which is a testament to vegeta's
awesomeness and power vegeta with the
fist still on his face says that granola
can believe what he wants but he's
telling the truth and he says don't
think for a second that he wants
granola's pity so even though they were
through a similar experience it's
interesting how vegeta handles it and
looks at it compared to granola he's
moved beyond it you could say while
granola is still stuck in the past we
see another unique move with granola
when he uses his scarf to wrap around a
tower instead of blasting off like team
rocket this lets him land nicely on the
building oatmeal keeps reasoning with
granola by saying the sains were victims
as well and these saiyans weren't aware
or part of the attack on his people
granolas finally had enough in drops
oatmeal choosing to fight without the
support since he is the strongest again
it's hard to sympathize with a character
this bent on revenge especially when the
targets of revenge are not even the
individuals who did him wrong that's
what's missing from this revenge story
compared to something like the catamonte
crystal where the protagonist has all
the reasons in the world to hate the
individuals he's planning his revenge on
by the way if you haven't read it i
definitely recommend it and there's even
an anime but back to granola and his
blind revenge there's an interesting
twist here where vegeta again mentions
granola's lack of experience and this
fight has definitely seemed to emphasize
vegeta getting stronger and stronger so
far but as granola points out he in fact
was not the only one getting stronger
granola was getting experience through
this battle as well and says that he is
growing stronger the more he fights too
i really like this detail because it
shows that this new vegeta could have
probably beat granola at granola's full
power when he was fighting goku for
example but granola has gotten stronger
since then too this time granola sends a
tower at vegeta and vegeta brings up how
granola is so willing to destroy his own
city now but yeah granola has lost it
and is sending building debris at vegeta
vegeta's god destruction power seems to
be too much for him to overcome so far
though side note we get a scene where
oatmeal is just picked up by a
self-driving ship ufo style oatmeal is
definitely an interesting detail that's
been focused on throughout this arc i
look forward to seeing how that pans out
we get to the point where vegeta and
granola are exchanging blows until
finally although vegeta gets the last
hit he's bleeding big time and in a lot
of pain he still takes comfort in it
though thinking it'll just make him
stronger which seems kind of crazy at
this point but to his credit though he
finally starts dodging some shots in the
meantime goku notices that granola's
moves are in fact sharper than ever and
that he is getting the hang of fighting
confirming that he is stronger aka a
better fighter than he was when he
confronted goku earlier goku is just
focusing on healing now and in theory he
should get a power boost too after
taking so much damage from granola
vegeta though looks like he's doing well
at moments landing attacks on granola
but he's not holding up well at all his
vision is blurring and he admits that
he's taken far too much damage it's a
catch-22 in a sense because he seemingly
needs to take more damage to get
stronger faster but the damage is also
taking him out of the fight faster
granola though seems to be in contrast
in pretty alright shape then we get a
highlight of this chapter vegeta
launches a massive spear bomb of
destruction obviously it's not
technically a spirit bomb but you know
what i mean it looks like it that will
destroy anything it touches even the
planet so granola has to stop it as
vegeta tells him to do now arguably
vegeta lost it here and went too far
with his battle craziness and is putting
goku and everyone on the planet at risk
very uncharacteristic of the vegeta who
wanted to atone for what he did to
namekians he even tells granola that
this will be granola's doom let me know
your thoughts on this is there an excuse
for vegeta launching this destructive
move did he think granola would stop it
or has this form really let him astray
from his recent principles luckily for
granola and goku and even vegeta who
can't breathe in space granola awakens
his second shot and gone aka his second
eye becomes red too a clear physical
sign that he's grown stronger during
this battle he launches an energy beam
that does in fact destroy vegeta's
attack causing a massive explosion but
not big enough to actually destroy the
planet or kill anybody now vegeta is on
the ground and granola thanks him since
vegeta is responsible for drawing out
this power importantly vegeta is still
in his new form so we shouldn't count
him out yet but i also have to say who
cares if vegeta doesn't get a clear w
here neither did goku and vegeta did
great forcing granola to reach new
levels of power that goku couldn't bring
out of him with his multiple tries so
far and he's still not down for the
count i feel like vegeta fans me
included have plenty to appreciate about
this chapter and not getting a clear w
right off the bat should not sour
anyone's mood vegeta did great power
wise i just look forward to learning
more about why he launched that attack
to destroy the planet because we have
seen moments of rationality in this form
as well it's not like he's always losing
it time will make this clear for sure
now we just need ultra instant god of
destruction gogeta and we're good to go
lastly we meet up with the heaters who
are glad to see the strong fighters
taking each other out and move towards
the first location of the dragon balls
this tells me that we might get a good
deal of fighting left before the heaters
really come into play since they're only
heading for the first location now all
in all a solid chapter and i found
plenty to like in it i got what i wanted
in terms of vegeta's impressive power
upgrade he definitely surpassed goku so
far by pushing granola to awaken his
second shotting gun and i respect that i
don't need him to crush the strongest
fighter in the world easily after
getting a new form even if vegeta isn't
the one to defeat granola i am totally
satisfied with what we saw from him in
the last two chapters totally epic with
an asterisk there for trying to destroy
the planet as always let me know what
you thought of this chapter did you
enjoy it as much as i did or are you
dissatisfied with vegeta's performance
i'd love to hear what you think below if
you do enjoy seeing these dragon ball
super reviews and want to keep them
coming channel the god destruction
within and destroy that like button that
pun alone deserves a like if you have it
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future dragon ball super and
vegeta updates and as i said no one
wants to miss vegeta updates and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]